[Music]
you were named Hollywood's hottest
bachelor by People magazine and what
they did here is they took my body and
put your head on which I did not agree
to but that's that's quite a quite an
achievement I know how you feel about
that does it embarrass you or you think
like a it's just fun uh it's a lot of
fun I mean the whole joke was you know
as soon as you're Bachelor of the Year
it's not gonna last very long all right
you know of course you know I come from
Pittsburgh and a good buddy of mine
Billie back home was voted Pittsburgh
sexiest bachelor so he called me to let
me know that whenever I'm back I'm
number two to put it all in perspective
that were you you know what you did
something interesting this came out and
of course a lot of people you know
talking about Wow such a good-looking
guy and you did an interesting thing you
you put out you released a photo of
yourself as a kid to kind of give people
everywhere hope well that fair to say I
did well I wrote I wrote a book about
about bodybuilding about fitness called
evolution and you know you hear people a
lot of times think they all think that
celebrities that they watch in the film
and in T V pop out of the womb rent and
you know that wasn't the case with me we
don't know we don't we have to work at
it
don't laugh at him he wait this is let's
just show the picture of you as a kid
because this is quite yeah in the book
on page 1 it starts with my before
picture and then we showed the after
this before and after because together I
think we have that yeah it looks like
the you then now you is bullying the
younger you four-eyes you're not being
nice to him
you